not hello my name in the eyes choice
bengio i am a professor at the university
of montreal and scientific director of
mila i am now going to talk about my
research program
my collaborators and i are trying to
draw inspiration from our understanding of the
limits of current systems so  there
really is still a big step between
today's artificial intelligence systems and even a two-year-old child
so it inspires us to look at
how animals humans build a
model of the world around them that it will
allow to  to understand this
environment of causal relations
in the environment and so on and to
reason in this environment, which
attracted me from the start to this field
of research in
artificial intelligence and in particular to the
field of neural networks which  has
become deep learning is that
on the one hand intelligence is
probably one of the biggest mysteries
that science tries to
understanding and on the other hand those this
particular
learning-based approach lies at
the intersection of two big questions
in relation to intelligence
how are humans and
animals capable of
making intelligent decisions and how is
that we can build intelligent machines
and the idea is that they
would have universal principles if we
want them
to answer these two
questions the Canadian strategy has
already come out girl sky which is based in
part on  the sheikh dia so strong are
it's very important because the country
will develop in the next few
years largely economically
and in the social benefits to people
thanks to artificial intelligence and
if we develop this expertise and this
economy from  of our talents here we
will be able not only to influence it
in a positive way but also to
benefit from it economically and therefore the
sinews of war in this development  oppement
is the talent that is to say the people
who are in canada and who have this
expertise
then the starting point of this talent
is what happens in the
universities with professors their
students the post doc and its  ranks which
are the core around which
a whole new economy will be grafted
[Music]